I might not know say woody things I'm
pulling your string no okay I'm pretty
sure all right we'll kill me no maybe
you make your skins I gotta pick my skin
let me live for one more second please
music gonna be a problem oh my god
you're slime Oh amazing
you're literally Slimers hiss so cool
hey Who am I yeah I've got a expansive
knowledge on many popular cultural
references and Carib melons are huge
thank you I owe that button also my sub
bazongas are booming stay still let me
see if I could shoot your legs even
though they're not there because I'm
never fect Liese
did oh god what's happening wow that's
what I look like let's be let's be
reasonable wait let's be cool I'm gonna
spend a lot of time dead hope you guys
don't mind well I mean it's a good thing
we're not doing deathmatch here we're
trying to build okay hey come here bring
it put it in the pool I think my bear is
moving in slow motion here and that
didn't work at all
I see moving so slowly was bond visible
I don't know can you not see the bear
where's Bob am i invisible Bob where are
you
yep are you back here with us are you in
the pool yeah I'm in the pool what no
you're not hang on what we'll do a test
get off my face what are you talking
about oh you're right I'm not in there
that's right you doing back here you
wanna play a game
um yes okay so how do I do that oh my
god I hover bald myself that was a
mistake
Bob I don't think that's working very
well oh my god you got a look at the
walk cycle on this guy
that's amazing can it hurt us probably
know it it can't hurt us
no definitely not whoa taken your boobs
uh-huh poison my hole I'll defend myself
balls what is this nothin just wants to
take your picture cuz you're so famous
hey you let it go Oh God do you enjoy
that wait where are you I'm dead on the
ground Bob
where'd you died see what I'm talking
about waiting well that is that is gonna
be the thumbnail right there oh that
didn't work what is that something this
car seems a little janky hop in hop in
Bob and then I don't know if I can just
use right yeah I can't get in there okay
hey come back here I need to pimp your
suck so much weight jeez all you can do
is rocket people know Bob hooptie hoop
up you uh
Oh God Oh God sat down and what Oh in
the chair okay hang on let me let me
pimp your ride all right okay thanks for
putting it on the bottom there now I
know